normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have a tweet from Steven Crowder
Facebook is now censoring the Nashville
Manifesto this is what we saw almost
immediately after the story broke this
is what the news uh uh this is what big
tech companies do many news media
Outlets they didn't want to cover the
story social media companies don't want
to uh uh get into any kind of debate and
this is a serious problem we now know
based on local reporting and statements
from from local politicians the leaks
from Steven Crowder are real and at the
time Facebook was taking them down
Google had their stupid alert when you
searched for it saying the results are
changing rapidly here are some other
stories instead which is what they do
and they don't want you to read these
stories here's what happens big tech
companies basically say if it doesn't
come from the New York Times we will not
allow it if however you get 5,000 local
Outlets reporting it then there's
nothing they can do to stop it but they
tried to stop it mhm and so fortunately
I guess local new immediately jumped on
the story broke through and the story
made it out I think one of the biggest
fears that Facebook and YouTube and uh
uh many of these other platforms not
Rumble not X for instance Their Fear
Steven Crowder just set the news cycle
right and and the New York Times is
going to try to avoid it they're going
to be like no no no no don't pick up his
story we're the ones who decide what
people are talking about but they've
been losing that position step Crowder
uh uh was questioned by these news how
do you know it's real and we stand by
reporting and it is a political comedian
on Youtube who broke the biggest story
today because of people in their Network
I mean from what I understood from what
he was saying during his live stream it
was someone involved in mug Club who was
like I have a contact I know way to get
this and they were able to verify
through that that's pretty impressive
right I mean this is all journalists
rely on their readers for tips this is
super normal but it is interesting that
he has built such a relationship that
someone would be willing to potentially
take and I don't know who the source was
like a professional risk to get them
this information that that shows a lot
of confidence in stepen Crowder it's
citizen journalism that is not citizen
journalism well but the citizen appla
gave the the journalism to Crowder to
amplify the message that's an aspect of
like citizen journalism so this is I I I
the idea that this is citizen journalism
was created to discredit people like
Steven Crowder I know this because I was
I was I was at these conventions I was
at these conferences and I was speak at
these events and they kept saying you're
just a citizen journalist and I said no
citizen journalism is a guy walking his
dog and then all of a sudden he sees a
plane in the sky on fire so he pulls out
his phone and films and it crashes and
he goes whoa and then he tweets a video
I guess there's no way to know who it
was that that delivered didn't didn't
give it to Fox but this but but that's
meaningless the New York Times has
sources all day every day someone in law
enforcement releases information the New
York Times publishes it Steven Crowder
is no different from the New York Times
granted he is a ComEd Median on YouTube
but his news apparatus that got this
information and published it is the same
as Wikileaks uh uh system the same as
New York Times system you have someone
who liases with a source The Source
provides information the information is
vetted and then
reported I just think it's cool that
this is something he has built right
when he was posting videos initially on
YouTube I'm sure he did not expect to be
in the position he is today which is
that he decided what the news was going
to be out I mean he came out with this
on a Monday for a reason this is going
to lead the news cycle at least for the
next cou days probably through the end
of the week it it and it this may
actually Force the release of the full
full Manifesto which is probably the
only way we would have gotten it out so
the one of the ideas that's being put
out on on on X on social media is that
these are select pages and that in
reality while everyone's highlighting
the anti-white sentiment that seems to
have motivated the shooter there's way
more in there and this person hates
everybody and uses slurs for everybody
but the selective page The Selective
release right would would make it seem
like it was
one-sided yeah I mean I think that's
reasonable I I wouldn't be surprised if
it's you know not that I want to make
predictions about such a dark document
but I wouldn't be surprised if there's a
consistent anti-white theme because I
think as far as I can tell Audrey Hill
was white and I think a lot of people
who are raised in uh or who are coming
up in Progressive spheres are trained to
hate themselves especially if they're
white well if you look at what was said
in it the the the perpetrator says
things like private schools and fancy
khakis and she attended that school it
was very Marxist esque it was very
oppressor versus oppressed she was
taking this back to the oppressors and
she was going to get the justice and she
hoped she had a high kill count she said
things like that in the document and
that's where the mark like I I posted
about something critical about public
schools the other day about how they're
teaching Marxism to our kids and
somebody commented and said they don't
teach Marxism at Public Schools I'm like
you don't explicitly have to give out a
book by Marx to be teaching Marxism it's
this idea of this oppressor versus this
oppressed thing this critical theory
thing and when you just Ram that down
people's heads you end up like
militarizing and radicalizing an entire
generation yeah they indoctrinate people
with Marxism they don't unfortunately as
far as I know actually teach the
theories of Marxism enough they should
probably teach that more so that you can
realize if you were being indoctrinated
no no teaching in public school if they
taught actual Marxist theory along with
history of Marxism the children would be
crying by the end of the day and say why
would anyone ever do such a thing those
poor people the hundred 100 million who
are 1958 1962 Great Leap Forward
it's so easy to be like we're all in
this together let's go all of us and
then once the revolution happens it's
like between 1958 and 1962 then white
supremacism did between 1619 and 2019
yeah how many people did it in from four
years estimates of 100 million during
the Great Le forward during the Great
lead forward in China they starved no I
don't think it was 100 million in four
years those are the high estimates 100
million yes 1958 1962 look up the Great
Leap Forward on Wikipedia I believe
estimates go as high as 100 million
there are lower ones that are in like
the 50 60 range
room is filled with rapid typing 30 30
and 45 30 and 45 yeah 100 is the total
deaths of Communism I'm pretty sure yeah
I don't know you got to grab the mic
brother yeah give it to me Serge what's
the word we can't no we can't hear you
no one else can't either yeah yeah in
the 100 million is over the entire
period of Comm of communist China not
necessarily from
like it's not no that's all communism
okay I believe that there is a study
that estimates that 100 million Chinese
died specifically from the Great Leap
Forward but it might not be the most
widely accepted study but I'm almost
positive that on the Wikipedia page for
the Great lead forward Wikipedia says 55
is the high and and 15 is the is
Wikipedia we do have take a grain of
salt but I believe you I mean I think
this is one of those things where why
would they well it's not that bad if
it's only 50 million jeez 50 million
people no I think way more than the
Holocaust it's like 10 times more and
this is like the greatly forward I mean
I can try and explain it it's when he
took like a bunch of the the teachers
and things and then he sent them out to
the farms and was like we got to yeah he
wanted no it's the other way around he
wanted to industrialize the the nation
of China to make it a factory based sort
of exporter and so he took all the
agricultural people and put them in the
cities so nobody was working the Farms
then everybody that was in responsible
for the districts of the Farms was too
scared to report to their higher ups
they weren't meeting quotas on harvest
because China's you know communism
you're scared to tell your boss you're
not meeting numbers and so they didn't
realize that there was like a mass
shortage of food until it was too late
and everybody starved over like four
years that's why I I always feel like
you can't trust any numbers that come
out of China because number one why
would they report anything accurately to
the outside world anyways and also why
would they internally report accurately
there's no there's no benefit for them
you know but why would the US yeah I
tweeted this out over the weekend Tik
Tok may be Chinese Communist propaganda
but Facebook and YouTube are American
Communist that was what the fourth was
all about shout out to Elon Musk we were
liting X and to Chris pavlovski for
making Rumble and for lifting up the
fourth pillar that's what these guys are
doing it's supposed to be a fourth
branch of government it's not really but
it's the fourth estate it's journalism
it's the journalists that keep the
politicians to task that cover the
government and make sure it's it's
honest and that unfortunately the
fascism involved with the digitalization
of our news media has been way too easy
for the government to corrupt so I'm I'm
happy to see organizations like mines
Rumble and X holding the truth like like
uh Rumble they tweeted out on X we're
holding the line about Crowder's post
they're not going to block it like this
like this Facebook did yeah shout out it
all started with Cambridge analytica
after they blamed the election of Donald
Trump in 2016 on social media all of a
sudden all of the big tech companies got
really scared and really ramped up their
censorship because I think that there
was this either explicit or like
unstated threat they felt like the
government was going to come in and
split them up if they didn't do
something what was the Cambridge Scandal
I don't I don't think it was that you
don't think so I think it was that they
were just once again trying to
manipulate and control the system for
sure yeah so Cambridge analytica had
access to what was it like 40 million
bunch of data that was allegedly used to
win the election for Trump and it's and
I think it's complete nonsense the idea
was that this company came altica and uh
group had access to user data which they
use to Target voters and the reason why
you know that's stupid and nonsensical
is that uh we've talked to Dr Robert
Epstein who's pointed out that Google I
I love this we can simplify the
algorithm manipulation electoral
argument with a very very simple
statement Facebook sends reminders to
Democrats on Election Day and not to
Republicans that's the only thing they
need to do to steal an election they
still do that so according to Dr Epstein
who appeared on the culture war two
weeks ago when they were tracking their
user their like 10,000 plus user group
for uh studying their their social media
experiences they found that 59% of
Republicans received a reminder but 100%
of Democrats received a reminder oh that
sounds like that should be illegal yes
and when kind absolutely and when Ted
Cruz wrote a letter saying what you are
doing you know we have questions about
this he said they saw instantly Google
turned the bias system off in Georgia so
that means that's the implication is
Google is intentionally manipulating
elections oh man I made a video in 2007
I was like vote Barack Obama you're
going to win the election vote for
Barack Obama everyone Barack you're the
next president and I was like manip I
felt like I was manipulating the
election I mean in a way I was like it's
your fault man Google they actually
featured that video and put it on the
front page of the news and politics
section talk about interfering like it
not it was not illegal but it was just
Mass manipulation of vote for my guy
right when they when they pushed your
video probably because there's not an
equal representation right it's it's
whoever is willing to support Obama can
be on the front page but anyone else
does not get to be on the trending page
does not get to exist at all it was
total political bias both me and the guy
that featured me wanted Obama to win so
I feel like yours isn't manipulative
like if you really feel like they should
vote for Obama you have a platform you
can say that right it's different when
YouTube decides certain videos get to
make it to to the front page certain
videos get to be boosted by the
algorithm and it's not equally applied
right I mean we know this through our
own experiences I mean you're on YouTube
there are certain videos that you know
are performing well that do not make it
to the pages or list that they should
because YouTube is intentionally
diverting them elsewhere it's not always
in the best interest of the business
either like when they censor people like
Alex Jones from YouTube that was we're
talking like hundreds of millions of
views consistently and so it seems to me
like almost a betrayal of the
shareholders of the company when you're
bringing people off the platform just
for iCal motives I wonder if there's a
lawsuit Avenue there because there's a
duty to do to honor what you what's in
the best interest of the shareholder so
the fact that there's a political
motivation that seems to transcend the
monetary motivation seems to me to imply
that there's this Twitter files thing
going on but with all these other
platforms whether there's just
intelligence Community operatives just
kind of but we do know that uh Nancy
Pelosi is net worth her and her
husband's around $200 million so it's uh
the political is monetary yeah the
political motivation uh and and let me
just say what a strange an unfortunate
coincidence that the uh Clinton Global
initiative or the Clinton Foundation I
believe their uh their contributions
dried up shortly after Hillary Clinton
lost the election just what a coin they
just restarted it too didn't they the
Clinton foundation for to rebuild
Ukraine that's what they said so the
general idea is this the idea was that
the expectation with Hillary becoming
president everybody's donating money to
her foundation which is a laundering I
guess and then the idea is if she
becomes president then those favors get
paid back they purchased something but
she lost and this what I really really
love I just want to shout out the 2016
was you know the that election oh boy I
remember that night oh so well all the
Trump all the all the Trump supporter
well I'm sorry I was at the sputnick
office with Cassandra Fairbanks and um
Cassandra McDonald sorry and uh she was
the only Trump supporter there everyone
else was upset people were crying and
she was laughing crying and it was funny
but what was really funny about it was
that the establishment machine of money
churn and and revolving doors was just
shattered and an instant and the Panic
was absolutely hilarious for the DC
Elites who owed millions of dollars to
foreign donors and lobbyists that they
weren't going to be able to to uh pay
back now you have Matt Gates doing the
same thing to Kevin McCarthy and all of
that money put into him becoming speaker
was just ripped away from him and he
ain't going to be able to pay it back I
just love watching the machine get
ripped to shreds yeah anyway purpose of
the United States oh sorry what do mean
that this this whole United States
Revolution away from the the machine of
the British Empire I mean the whole
point is ripping that thing to shreds
and creating a new system that's way
better American republicanism thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net